tout d'abord donc l'attentât odieux
il était un peu plus de neuf heures ce
matin lorsqu'une explosion de très forte
puissance a retenti tout près des champs
elysées
cette voiture un véhicule piégé venait
d'exploser face au 33 de la rue marbeuf
la victime est une femme de 30 ans nelly
guillerme
l'attentât a eu lieu très précisément
devant les locaux d'un vin de madère
libyen al watan al arabi un magazine pro
irakien et donc anti syrien toute la
journée les équipes vingtaine de se sont
mobilisés pour enquêter
voici le résultat de leur travail tout
d'abord les faits et faits bruts avec
dennis blair il est 9h ce matin rue
marbeuf près des champs elysées c'est
l'heure où des centaines de personnes se
rendent à leur bureau ou dans les
boutiques à 9h01 cette voiture en
stationnement devant le numéro 33
explose la déflagration est si forte
qu'elle souffle façades et vitrines dans
un rayon de 150 mètres tu une personne
effet 63 blessés le véhicule piégé une
opel de couleur orange loué en autriche
immatriculé à vienne se trouvait devant
la façade du journal libanais al watan
al arabi un jeune employé de ce journal
témoin le moment chauffage et l apôtre à
la hauteur de l'entrée du garage
je sais pas bon je marchais je n'ai pas
regardé j'ai entendu
j'ai été projeté en l'air je me suis
retrouvée dans le garage vous êtes tombé
puis fonde maintenant l'entrée du garage
à un moment je compte acheter vu la dame
l'axé mars à tremblay devant moi c'est
tout comme
vous travaillez dans le journal qui
es-tu si oui alors vous pensez que ça un
lien bah oui on a lyon on a déjà eu une
alerte à la bombe au mois de décembre en
solo des lettres de menace régulièrement
régulièrement tout est quoi les mena bon
on va tout faire sauter
le journal était gardé la nuit temps en
temps on y avait des coups de téléphone
ça va faire boum 2 minutes après je
n'avais plus pour cinq minutes à vivre
on bat se garent mal que ça arrive avant
journalistes au liban il se fait sauter
régulièrement balles à taëz pour
quelquefois paris une jeune femme de 30
ans nelly guilherme a été tué sur le
coup quant au blessé le plus gravement
atteint
il s'agit d'un jeune homme de 18 ans
dont la jambe gauche a été à demi
arrachés
un homme de 61 ans qui ne fait rien
poignet qui fut également à voir
sauver la voix également envoie à midi
les services de secours dégagent est
encore les victimes de cet attentat
c'est dans un café transformé pour les
circonstances en infirmerie que les
premiers soins à leur était donnée avant
leur admission dans cinq hôpitaux
parisiens
à une centaine de mètres du lieu de
l'explosion se trouve une école
fréquentée par plusieurs centaines
d'enfants